[Music]
while tom hardy's dual performances
eddie brock and venom might have stolen
your attention venom let there be
carnage has some pretty important
characters and relatively minor roles
some pay tribute to the comics while
others might hint at future film stories
here are the characters that mean more
than you realize in venom keep in mind
heavy spoilers follow
portrayed by striking white-haired
veteran uk tv actor shan weber dr pazzo
is the cruel uncaring administrator
behind the endless incarceration of
inmates like francis barrison at the
beginning of let there be carnage she's
there to accept shriek when she arrives
decades later she's still at ravencroft
when cletus cassidy comes to rescue the
love of his life carnage's tentacles
lift dr pazzo off the ground and
strangle the not-so-good doctor while
the baddies make a prison break the
character has a small but noteworthy
history in marvel comics beginning with
1995's venom carnage unleashed volume 1
number 1. in that comic she's introduced
as a psychiatrist for cletus cassidy
rather than shriek by 1996 paso was
being presented as something of an
expert on symbiotes advising the police
and trying to help solve murders that
was pretty much the last appearance of
the character until now and let there be
carnage there are multiple references to
cassidy's abuse at his father's hands
how he murdered his grandmother and even
the family dog while the details have
been changed a bit without the pazzo
character in the comic books we wouldn't
have a lot of that information so in
essence the movie has shifted paso's
focus from cassidy to barrison and
turned her into much more of an evil
prison warden-like character
portrayed by veteran character actor
stephen graham patrick mulligan plays a
pivotal role in all the lives of the
film's main characters he can first be
seen in flashback that opens the film as
francis barristan is being moved from
saint estes reform school to ravencroft
while attempting to make an escape from
a moving vehicle mulligan shoots shriek
in the eye thinking he's killed her and
nearly losing his hearing in the battle
decades later the now detective mulligan
is overseeing the escalating crime
investigations around san francisco he's
suspicious of eddie brock but unaware
that he has a murderous symbiote sharing
his body instead mulligan just seems to
think eddie is a weird dude why would he
think that i have proof
[Music]
well fair enough when eddie realizes
that cletus cassidy is on a mission to
free francis barrison mulligan insists
that she's dead but soon learns the
truth and also discovers that shriek has
been holding a serious grudge against
him this all culminates in an engraved
invitation to the so-called red wedding
where mulligan is a guest of honor after
the inevitable showdown with shriek
mulligan lives to fight another day but
seems to have developed glowing blue
eyes and a fascination with the word
monster unless you think mulligan is
just another generic cop he is likely
based on patrick mulligan a prominent
character in venom and carnage comics
from the 2000s his story began in venom
carnage number one and number two as
carnage birthed the symbiote that would
come to be known as toxin mulligan a new
york city cop became its host and
expectations were that toxin would
become a hero because of mulligan's
career but as time went on mulligan
developed a fear and paranoia about
having toxin around his wife and newborn
son and although he assisted heroes like
spider-man and the avengers he struggled
with his newfound powers even allowing
toxin at one point to murder a criminal
eventually mulligan himself was killed
and the symbiote toxin went on to other
hosts de mulligan's glowing blue eyes
indicate that steven graham might have
some toxic behavior ahead of him while
marvel fans might hope so we'll likely
have to wait until the next venom movie
to learn more
during what has to be the most surreal
scene of venom let there be carnage the
recently separated venom infiltrates
what looks to be some kind of pride
adjacent rave where its inhabitants
assume the symbiote is a person in a
really cool costume it then drunkenly
storms the stage rants about eddie and
becomes a hero to those in attendance
posters publicizing the event lists the
talent as little sims and that is who
venom takes the microphone away from mid
performance the 27 year old british
nigerian artist is no character but in
fact an experimental rapper who has
opened for the likes of gorillas earned
praise from kendrick lamar and appeared
previously on the netflix show top boy
in the bbc children's series spirit
warriors little sims also released a
song in 2019 called venom which doesn't
seem to directly reference alien
symbiotes but is peppered with so many
words that can't be repeated in this
video that all you need to know is the
chorus is a multiple repetition of the
word venom shortly before venom let
there be carnage arrived in theaters she
released her fourth studio album
entitled sometimes i might be introvert
according to director andy circus the
little sims cameo came about because of
tom hardy circus told uprox she actually
had made a song unbeknownst to her
called venom that connected very much
with the first movie and so tom got in
touch with her and that song became sort
of the focus circus revealed that the
scene was originally written not as a
rave but a quote carnival of the damned
party who is credited on the film not
only as a star but also a co-writer
sounds like he was a driving force
behind the scene tom and co-writer kelly
marcel were always about venom coming
out and going to a party that was very
sort of an lgbtqia kind of festival this
is venom's coming out party check out
one of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about venom are
coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]
you